[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
friday june 24th i'm zoe thomas for the
wall street journal
july marks one year since andy jassy
took over as ceo of amazon
for amazon insiders he was a familiar
face he spent more than two decades
there and had been running the cloud
computing division amazon web services
the company's cash cow
but since his promotion it's been a
bumpy ride one that's forced him to undo
some decisions made by his mentor and
the company's founder jeff bezos
to break down what jassy's first year as
ceo has been like and what it tells us
about the e-commerce giant's future is
our amazon reporter dana matioli hi dana
thanks for being here hi thanks for
having me
so dana what situation did jesse inherit
when he first took over
andy started on july 5th 2021 and if you
remember that was a time when people
were still relying on e-commerce and
you know when earnings were coming in
companies like amazon were just killing
it they were you know above their
estimates and amazon actually posted
record earnings so that's sort of the
amazon he walked into taking over but
behind the scenes things had started to
change you know customers had become
more comfortable shopping in person
again they actually liked it it wasn't
you know viewed as a chore it was nice
to get out and about
and all of this infrastructure that
amazon built to deal with this
unprecedented demand became too much
just given the change in shopping habits
and so how has jesse been dealing with
that change what's he been doing to help
amazon through this shifting period
once he took over it quickly became
apparent that there are plans for this
massive build-out of more warehousing
and sortation centers and logistics
network
was way too big they weren't going to
need all that so quickly they started
just slashing their forecasts on that
build out and part of the plan has been
to sublease all the space that they
bought to delay building these very
expensive warehouses that they don't
need right now
and to stop hiring in the warehouses
because they don't need quite as many
people fulfilling these orders if
there's fewer than they were expecting
how did amazon end up in this situation
kind of overestimating how much capacity
it was going to need on the e-commerce
side
so back during you know the darkest days
of the pandemic you know before a
vaccine was like even on anyone's mind
amazon became flooded with all these
orders at the time jeff bezos was still
ceo and the company has this credo of
quote-unquote customer obsession
and basically that means doing whatever
it takes for the customer and i don't
know if you remember this but people
were hoarding toilet paper back then in
hand sanitizer and you know there were
shortages on the shelves because
everyone was just taking whatever they
can get and amazon was a destination for
a lot of this so they were running out
of
you know inventory their quick shipping
of two days extended to like more than a
month on some items so they greenlighted
this very very aggressive plan to grow
quickly to meet that demand the problem
with plans like that is that you can't
just turn the switch on overnight in
order to grow to meet that demand you
have to make capital allocation
decisions that take two years to execute
so while they committed to the spend and
building out these centers and all of
that
march 2020 it takes two years for them
to come online and that's where we are
now
so all of that extra capacity is coming
online now and jassy's saying you know
hey maybe we don't need it he's looking
at cuts and subleasing but how is that
being read inside amazon what do people
think of his leadership style i've heard
that there hasn't been you know any
disagreement between
those cuts and you know the people that
are implementing the cuts everyone
agrees that they were a little bit too
aggressive here
where there is some daylight is andy's
management style so he went from
managing cloud computing at amazon which
was very siloed off of the rest of
amazon and so different
you know it's not really a
consumer-facing business it's b2b
it's very technical it's tons of
engineers you know
the rest of amazon is you know shopping
prime it's alexa it's
just very different than cloud computing
and at aws andy was a very very hands-on
manager
in the details in the weeds whereas at
amazon you know there are
lots of senior leaders who could be ceos
of publicly traded companies on their
own that's how big their orgs are
running things and you had jeff bezos
sort of floating above as the ceo that
was not
at least in recent years very hands-on
and now that andy's the ceo i think part
of it is any new ceo would sort of make
the rounds and understand the business
and ask lots of questions but his
attention to detail and
his different ways of managing have
rubbed some people the wrong way and it
even was part of the reason that the
person in charge of all of the consumer
business and logistics business decided
to leave in the middle of this problem
what about in terms of amazon's board or
its investors what do they think of
jassy's style
the board is has really backed him
they think he's the right person to lead
the company in this time
investors have been a little bit less
patient you know the stock is down more
than 30 since andy took over and wall
street's not the most patient bunch and
because amazon employees are
compensated heavily in stock it's also
an issue on that front because
that's like a significant pay cut for a
lot of these employees and it could
cause people to leave or become antsy so
that is something that they will have to
figure out do we know what his plans are
to kind of move the business forward and
i guess maybe step out of the shadow of
jeff bezos a bit i think you know a lot
of his time will be dedicated to growth
you know like advertising is this
really big area for them that's really
high profit and it's growing really
quickly and project kuiper which is
small but of interest and there's all
these other areas that
could become the next growth areas but
he's also having to you know reel in
some things that aren't working you know
physical stores was launched under jeff
bezos and
they made a very significant cut there
they closed almost every physical store
except for grocery
in the last few months because it just
wasn't working so i think because andy
is new and he has this opportunity to
meet with all the division heads and go
over the numbers and ask all the
questions you could see some other
things get cut that he doesn't deem
worthy enough of keeping within the
company
all right so some changes coming to the
everything store i guess
all right that was our reporter dana
matioli thanks for being here dana thank
you
and that's it for tech news briefing
this week our producer is julie chang we
had editorial support from scott
salloway
our supervising producer is chris
sinsley our executive producer is
kateriocum
and i'm your host zoe thomas
thanks for listening and have a great
weekend
[Music]
you